[Musique]
pour sa première journée de visite à la
réunion sébastien lecornu ministre d
outre mer s'est rendu au palais de la
source où il s'est entretenu avec
cyrille melchior président du
département
une réunion de travail s'est ensuite
tenue dans l'hémicycle sur la gestion de
la crise sanitaire
durant près de deux heures sébastien
lecornu à échanger avec les élus locaux
nous allons de nouveau réinstituer sous
la présidence du préfet de région avec
la directrice générale de l'agencé
régionale de santé l'ensemble des chefs
de service de l'état une réunion
hebdomadaire de crise qui permet de
faire le suivi sur l'épidémie coville 19
le suivi en matière d'information la
cartographie les différents clusters
être en situation de regarder de près
comment le virus circule sur l'île par
quel biais y circulent
j'ai rappelé aussi tout à l'heure au
maire que le virus ne vient pas que par
l'importation de métropole où d'ailleurs
il circule aussi parce que
malheureusement un certain nombre de
précautions sanitaires ne sont pas
respectés sur place et in situ et
surtout on est sur une île en erreur
milieux prince eu l'air coordonner les
actions des mers entre maire de
saint-denis prendre des mesures sur en
lien avec le café dans son arrêté
préfectoral du port du masque
obligatoire dans certaines rues si on
est en limitrophes
d'autres communes qui eux ne prendre pas
forcément en miroir les mêmes décisions
on peut avoir un défaut de cohérence du
dispositif que nous mettons en place
ça c'était une demande des maires de la
réunion j ai fait droit le préfet
réunira dès la fin de semaine après mon
départ
cette réunion de travail de crise
d'organisation qui permettra à la fois
de faire circuler l'information et en
même temps de venir à un peu clarifiée
les différentes mesures et des
coordonnées entre les ministres a
annoncé qu à travers ce plan de soutien
massif l'état mettra la main à la poche
pour venir en aide aux communes
réunionnaises lourdement frappée par le
coronavirus face aux inquiétudes des
mères dans la gestion de crise et des
difficultés financières eh bien l'état
donc ministre à l'annoncé va accompagner
les communes de la réunion à hauteur de
60 à 100 millions d'euros donc tout cela
est en cours de discussion les projets
de loi de finances sont en préparation
mais toujours est il que des sommes donc
seront mises à disposition pour le
financement des communes poids ce qui
concerne le département le ministre nous
a annoncé que nous allons pouvoir
bénéficier d'une avance de 15 millions
d'euros au titre de la dotation des mt
au de façon à maintenir donc les
équilibres financiers du département et
donc voilée mais aussi comme je voulais
dire une annonce concrète de l'ordre de
60 millions d'euros
un peu plus même qui seront mobilisables
par les communes face à la crise autres
thèmes abordés lors de cette réunion la
situation des collectivités locales le
ministre a confirmé que les dotations de
l'état ont augmenté cette année de 7
millions d'euros pour la réunion et
continueront à augmenter l'année
prochaine
[Musique]